so basically what happened is that this
piece of garbage illegal immigrant and
he's not in a piece of garbage because
he's an illegal immigrant he's a piece
of garbage who is an illegal immigrant
he was walking around on the pier and he
has the gun the defense says that he
found the gun on the pier okay this is
like the lamest excuse ever how many
times you've been walking around just
find a gun lying around usually you're
walking around and boom look there's a
gun okay this it never happens and the
idea that this happens in San Francisco
on a regular basis is insane San
Francisco has some of the tightest gun
laws in the nation so he says that he's
walking around he finds a gun he picks
it up because he picks it up and then
magically the gun just goes off it is
clear from the evidence that the bullet
hit the cement before it hit Steinle so
it wasn't like he picked up the gun aim
did Stanley shot her in the back okay he
he picked up the gun he fired it it
bounced off the concrete it hit Kate
Steinle in the bag it killed her
and the the defense was that he
basically he's a that basically
was walking around her gun he picks it
up it goes boom in his hand for no
reason at all it's just a pure accident
the bullet bounces it skips off the
concrete and hits Kate Steinle in the
back and she dies the problem with this
particular theory is several-fold one
the gun had been missing for four days
from a federal agents car somehow it
just winds up in the hands with the see
legal immigrant criminal repeat criminal
agent magic it was like a normal person
who found it on the boardwalk over at
the San Francisco pier wasn't me it
wasn't you it was an illegal immigrant
who's been deported five times
hey just magically amazing how that
works he picks it up they they question
him and in during the questioning he
says that he was trying to fire it at
the seals they saw a see it that he saw
a seal out there or a sea lion he was
trying to fire it at sea lion and then
his story changed and he said that he
had that it fired by accident according
to according the San Francisco Chronicle
defense lawyer said the shooting was an
accident that happened when Garcia's
Addante
but a history of drug crimes but no
record of violence found the gun wrapped
in a t-shirt or cloth under his seat on
the pier just seconds before it
discharged in his hands because that's
what I do when I see like a bundle of
cloth under my seat at a public pier I
reach down they start investigating and
if I find a gonna go or good okay Matt
Gonzalez or the public defender's office
said his client had never handled a gun
yes I'm sure
and was scared by the noise prompting
him to fling the weapon into the bay
okay so number one if you accidentally
fire a gun
so apparently he says he was scared by
the noise it wasn't that it wasn't that
he shot the woman and then thought that
he would be convicted of it and so he
threw the evidence away into the bay
instead he took the gun and he threw it
in the bay because he was scared by the
noise that's what I do when my child
scares me my trout makes a really loud
noise when we're by the ocean I just
take my kid and fling him in the ocean
let me just tell you this is this is
something that normal people do on a
regular basis oh my god a car backfired
let's drive it into the ocean that's it
that's something that you're scared of
the fight oh my god a gun made noise
what is this boom boom stick okay during
the trial jurors watched video from
Garcia sera tease for our police
interrogation in which she offered
varying statements about his actions on
the pier number one when someone
constantly changes their story that's a
pretty good indicator they're not
telling the truth okay at one point he
said he had aimed at a sea animal at
another point he said the gun had been
under a rag that lay on the ground near
the waterfront and that it fired when he
stepped on it
and Zala said it was clear in the video
by the way guns don't fire when he step
on them just note to everybody yeah
there are people who are saying that was
a Sig Sauer and this is a Sig Sauer with
with a a quick trigger because it was
basically set up for a federal agent who
knows how to use it really had four
pounds of trigger pressure okay even if
it only has four pounds of trigger
pressure you can't step on a gun and it
fires okay as a typical rule that is
it's extraordinarily rare like something
has to actually push on the trigger in
order to make the gun fire it's not how
guns fire almost the unless that the the
hammer was already cocked or something
and Zala said it was clear in the video
that he had not that he did not fully
understand what the officers were asking
through an officer Spanish translation
well that's sort of his problem I mean
they're speaking Spanish them it's not
like they're speaking English and he
doesn't understand grainy foot a
surveillance footage taken by the camera
position a quarter mile away showed that
just before Garcia Zarate took a seat on
the pier a group of six people gathered
at the spot Gonzales it was possible
those people had discarded the gun that
killed Steinle yes I'm sure that's what
happened six people just gathered and
decided that instead of throwing the gun
in the bay to discard the gun which is
five feet away they decided what would
be better we need to get rid of this gun
you know but we'll just leave it lying
around best idea I've ever had we're not
gonna take this gun
toss it in the bank no we're just gonna
leave it right here for some poor
unsuspecting illegal immigrant to find
and randomly shoot a lady
okay so Stanley was not hit directly but
rather the bullet hit the concrete
ground and ricocheted up to hit her
the gun was a Sig Sauer been stolen four
days prior the defense also presented
evidence that the Sig Sauer has a
propensity
accidentally fire so it has a
hair-trigger in single action mode
apparently among well-trained users it
has a lengthy history of accidental
discharges okay accidental discharges
does not mean that you have not acted
with criminal negligence if you pick up
a gun and you point it anywhere near the
vicinity of people and your hand is
anywhere near the trigger that does not
count as a pure accident okay a gun is a
dangerous weapon everyone knows this
okay this is why you are taught when you
buy a gun when you train with the gun
you are tried never point the gun
anywhere you are not willing to kill
somebody
never point the gun to anywhere you're
not willing to destroy never have your
finger anywhere near the trigger if you
don't mean to fire it okay but the idea
is that again this guy stunts and he
walks up and he doesn't know what a gun
is it just looks like a fancy a fancy
cheese cutter and he picks it up and
then boom it goes off in his hand
because he never even touched the
trigger okay this is so they say that
this is the defense presenting a
reasonable doubt case and they said he's
a homeless illegal immigrant unfamiliar
with the gun and that's why okay so I
think that what happened here if you're
trying to make the best case for the
jury it's that there's a prosecutorial
overreach so they pushed hard for a
first-degree murder verdict or a
second-degree murder verdict which which
suggests that you must have intent
rather you have to have intent to have
killed involuntary manslaughter does not
require intent so the the prosecution in
this case said that he was playing like
a game of Russian Roulette in his head
and just shot the lady that's weak what
they should have charged was involuntary
manslaughter they overcharged which a
lot of prosecutors do they overcharged
what they should have done is charge and
voluntary manslaughter second-degree
murder in the in California is wilful
foot but not deliberate like for example
you fire a gun into a crowded room you
don't mean to kill any specific person
but you know there's a good possibility
somebody is going to die
willful but not deliberately involuntary
manslaughter in California the standard
is without malice without intent to kill
with reckless disregard for human life
so the difference between involuntary
manslaughter and excusable accident is
participation in either an unlawful act
not amounting to a felony I'd be picking
up an illegal gun or a lawful act
involving a high degree of risk of death
or great bodily injury that would
involve picking up a gun and points get
it anywhere in the vicinity of people
and in fact there's a law firm out here
in California that has a defense law
firm that has very good runs down on
this law and the exact example that use
been voluntary manslaughter is a woman
who's gonna fight with her husband
brandishing a gun at her husband the gun
accidentally goes off and kills her
husband right dad falls
involuntary manslaughter okay Jeff
Sessions has a statement this was
clearly involuntary manslaughter the
jury could have found that it's possible
they decided to just throw out
everything because the prosecutor didn't
do their job but whatever it is this is
an unjust verdict the guy should be in
prison for a very long time for at least
involuntary manslaughter and beyond that
the reason this is a political issue is
cuz this bastard never should have been
in the United States in the first place
he should not have been here no
President Trump when he says we need a
wall the reason we need a wall is
because it's not enough to just
repeatedly to poor people you actually
have to have some way of preventing them
from recrossing into the country because
you have sanctuary cities you have
places where these people can hide you
know Trump should be making hay while
the Sun shines out of this because he is
right this is why Trump won it's because
it's issues like the Kate Steinle issue
as I said last night on Fox News Jeff
Sessions issue the Attorney General
issued a statement the feds may bring
charges of their own Jeff Sessions said
when jurisdictions choose to return
criminal aliens to the streets rather
than turning them over to federal
immigration authorities they put the
public safety at risk
san Francisco's decision to protect
criminal aliens led to the preventable
and heartbreaking death of Kate Steinle
while the state of California sought a
murder charge for the man who caused
Miss Stanley's death a man who had not
have been on the streets of San
Francisco if the city simply honored an
ice detainer the people ultimately
convicted him a felon in possession of a
firearm so again once you're a felon in
possession of a firearm if that firearm
goes off and you kill somebody it's
pretty hard to see charging and
convicting someone of felony possession
of a firearm without also charging them
with and convicting them of involuntary
manslaughter in case like this the
Department of Justice will continue to
ensure that all jurisdictions placed the
safety and security of their communities
above the convenience of criminal aliens
there should be blowback on sanctuary
cities and it shouldn't have to do
anything with it with the verdicts here
if the guy was convicted there should
still be blowback on sanctuary cities so
that's that's worth while noting as well